[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fan corrections this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay and so far many challengers
probably what probably like a hundred
challengers no winners
why
because we don't make mistakes
well tonight a fan with the youtube
screen name wasonator
says he that's yeah
thinks that he caught a mistake he says
it happened when i was talking to
actress ashley benson about the golf
carts we used to get around the warner
brothers lot
on your episode tonight you spoke about
driving a golf cart on the freeway we
have one that's street legal we have a
street legal golf cart we can take ours
on the freeway if we want to i've had
people see me in our golf cart on the
405 freeway going 85 miles an hour
you mentioned how it was legal to drive
on the road which is correct however
it's considered a low speed vehicle
and with that
you're not allowed to drive it anywhere
where the posted speed limit is above 35
miles per hour
which includes the interstate and other
highways
so unfortunately to see you on the 405
in a golf cart
would be both highly legal and highly
dangerous
so
with that said
i got you
you are dead
wrong
[Music]
well was
nader
it looks like he got me this time
if only
there was footage of me driving to work
in a golf cart on the 405 freeway set to
music
that's right
if only
there was footage of me driving to work
in a golf cart on the 405 freeway
set to music
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
throat
so the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
reported teamcoco.com haha i found an
error we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chump meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]